smells like much holidays my name is
Seth Brundle mache and a lifestyle
curator here today I'm going to show you
how to to build a three amazing gourmet
recipes with this instant box wagon
cheese and they're all super affordable
and you can find every single ingredient
at your local grocery store no matter
where you live so first we're going to
start with a breakfast mac and cheese
then we're gonna move into our date
night mac and cheese and then finally
we're gonna do a kid-friendly mac and
cheese so let's get started with that
we're gonna start with our pregnant
first thing I did was I went ahead and
boiled off two boxes of mac and cheese
noodles but I parked the box says seven
to eight minutes I cook them for five
when you cook anything you always have
carryover heat so we want to anticipate
that we don't want mushy noodles and
it'll stop them from cooking when you
put them in fresh ice water so let's get
started on our breakfast mac n cheese we
have our flame on medium close to the
bottom of this beautiful equal parts pan
then I add my flour
what's that up gonna become like a face
just gonna let that do this thing for
like maybe another two minutes until it
starts to bubble one temperature nope
this is the beginning of our bechamel we
added our milk velvety some kosher salt
and freshly cracked black pepper
granulated garlic and then some onion
powder our instant box mac and cheese
powder we got a nice big velvety
bechamel base for all three of our
cheese sauces for all three of our mac
and cheese
our larger pan on medium-high heat and
I'm going to throw this beautiful
Applewood that cut bacon in there bacon
is in a good place we're about a minute
out from it being done so we're gonna
add some red bell pepper some red onion
to cook for only about a minute we don't
want them like fully softened because
there's one some of that texture some of
that bite and then we have a regular
play line with paper towels or this
paper towel just to drain off boom
that's off to the side it's gonna do its
thing
I'm gonna add about a third of our
Deschanel to much smaller sauce pan in
there two days I'm gonna add a cup of
some sharp white cheddar then I'm gonna
reserve a little bit for the cook
version let that melt demo saute bacon
red onion and red bell pepper that we
saute earlier I'm gonna add about a
third of our e-news and we're just gonna
fold get this in there neatly the last
bit of our sharp white cheddar and we're
just gonna start with the large egg
cracking our water is at a boil I'm
gonna add a splash of vinegar you want
to turn it down to a simmer when you
make a poached egg we just want to make
a wall pool and our sauce pan which was
always one of my favorite things to do
as a kid ladle that egg straight into
that water and we're gonna let that
simmer for about three minutes kitchen
towel to let it drain and that's it
so we're gonna get started on our date
night menu change
extra virgin olive oils are enough but
not too hot it's not smoking in that
picture so now our great frozen image so
you see our our garlic and our shallots
are nice and golden brown or saute
they're really fragrant they're in a
perfect place so I'm just gonna put
these off the side he'll go right to our
bechamel 1/2 a cup of Gouda cheese 1/2
cup parmigiana
we're gonna let that melt down you Chuck
parsley and lemon juice
our sauteed garlic and shallots it's
gonna whisk this up a little bit about 6
ounces of hand flag white premium crab
this is only $3.00 I'm 50 cent summer
noodles to the cipher let's get a ball
game and then I'm just gonna spoon this
as carefully as possible into a ramekin
I fill it to the top top and then just
like you do some of our parmesan so that
we have our date night and now for our
last and final McEntee and dish this is
one of my favorites because it's more a
little boy it's kid from roasted
broccoli is one of his favorites so like
I'm taste it a little later and see what
he thinks he's my most crucial event
arches
great so let's get started on that
recipe first we're gonna just dump our
broccoli want to our baking sheet and
this is 400 degrees for 20 minutes then
we're going to stop we're gonna flip
these florets and want to go for another
10 minutes Alyssa's roasted to
perfection as crispy as tender it still
has some texture and crunch so I'm just
gonna put that off to the side and let
it cool then I'm gonna take a cutting
board in my chef's knife and chop it up
really fine so we're just going to pour
the rest of our bechamel directly into
our other saucepan classic sharp cheddar
cheese a cup of that we're gonna melt it
down then I'm gonna add some of our
chopped roasted broccoli a little bit of
mustard powder macaroni
oh into a ramekin extra sharp cheddar
and that's it
[Music]